Sarah was at Pier 94 in New York City a couple days ago. It was the place of families of people who had worked in the World Trade Center were going to give DNA samples to police for use in identifying their loved ones. And she was standing in the parking lot.
莎拉几天前在纽约市的 94 号码头。那里是世贸中心工作人员的家属前往向警方提供 DNA 样本，以协助辨认亲人遗体的地方。她当时就站在停车场里。
Then I saw this guy walking around basically in a circle, looking at people. And he kept touching his hand to the top of his head, like kind of rubbing the top of his head. And his movements were so strange that I actually thought that maybe he was deranged a little bit. Then the circles got a little bit smaller, and he came closer to where I was.
接着我看到这个人在附近走来走去，基本是在兜圈子，观察着人群。他不停地摸着自己的头顶，好像在揉搓头顶一样。他的动作非常奇怪，我甚至以为他有点精神失常。随后圈子变得小了一些，他走到了离我更近的地方。
And then I just realized that he had a flyer pinned to his T-shirt. And the flyer had a picture of this guy, black and white pictures, and some writing on it.  And I realized he was somebody's relative.
然后我才注意到他的 T 恤上别着一张传单。传单上有这个人的照片，黑白照片，上面还有一些字。我意识到他是某人的亲属。
He'd been walking all over New York City, posting this flyer over a 40-block area. It had a picture of his father. He'd gone to the Armory. He'd filled out a missing persons report. He tried to reach other people in his father's office on the 93rd floor of the World Trade Center. He'd gone to every hospital. And he'd just given some DNA.
他在纽约市各处奔走，在 40 个街区的范围内张贴这张传单。上面是他父亲的照片。他去过军械库，填过失踪人口报告。他尝试联系过他父亲在世贸中心 93 楼办公室的其他同事。他跑遍了每一家医院，而且刚留下了 DNA 样本。
So I said, what are you going to-- what do you do now? And he said, I don't know. And he said it like-- not just like, I don't know. But he was like, I don't know where to go. I just-- he just had no idea where to go or what to do. And he couldn't go home. It was like, I think there's a sense like, as long as there's daylight, you should be traipsing around the city, you know, looking for whoever.
于是我问，你接下来打算——你现在做什么？他说，我不知道。他说的时候——不仅仅是说“我不知道”，而是那种“我不知道该去哪”。他完全不知道该去哪或该做什么。他没法回家。我想这是一种感觉，只要天还没黑，你就该在城里四处游荡，寻找某个人。
And it was still sort of early afternoon, and I could just tell. He just had no idea what to do, physically, with himself. He said, I was walking around over there, and I realized I was literally walking around in circles. And I don't know what to do.
当时还是下午早些时候，我看得出来。他完全不知道自己在身体上该干什么。他说，我一直在那边走，然后发现自己简直是在原地打转。我不知道该怎么办。
What's so strange is that it wasn't just people touched so directly by the tragedy who felt that. Don't you feel like we've all been in a little bit of a fog? It's hard to sleep. It's hard to know what to think of things. We want to help somehow, but beyond a few simple things, it is not clear what to do or how to do it.
最奇怪的是，不仅仅是那些直接受到这场悲剧影响的人才有这种感觉。你不觉得我们所有人都有点迷茫吗？很难入睡。很难知道该对这些事情作何感想。我们想以某种方式提供帮助，但除了几件简单的事情外，并不清楚该做什么或怎么做。
Walking in circles is such a primal response. A friend who was in Washington Square Park in New York when the World Trade Center buildings collapsed said that a man that he was standing there started walking in circles at that moment, screaming. And maybe it's just me. But before last week, I could have never imagined the feeling that would lead to somebody doing that. But now I can.
兜圈子是一种非常原始的反应。我的一位朋友在世贸中心大楼倒塌时正身处纽约华盛顿广场公园，他说当时他身边的一个人开始原地转圈，并大声尖叫。也许只是我这样。但在上周之前，我从未想象过会导致一个人做出那种举动的情感。但现在我可以了。
In Chicago where I live, when I'm in the car driving around, I find myself obsessively staring at the Hancock Center and the Sears Tower, two buildings that are about as large as the World Trade Center buildings. And I look at them and try to get my mind around the scale of it. About what it means for something so crazily big to come tumbling to the ground. For two of them. Two somethings that big.
在我居住的芝加哥，当我开车四处行驶时，发现自己会不由自主地盯着汉考克中心和西尔斯大厦看，这两座建筑和世贸中心大楼差不多大。我看着它们，试图去理解这种规模的概念。理解如此庞大的东西轰然倒塌意味着什么。还是两座。两座如此巨大的建筑。
Somebody told me that for the first week that this happened, she slept with the radio on because she didn't want to miss the chance that somebody would explain why this happened. And don't you feel this? That no matter how much we've all learned in the last two weeks about Osama bin Laden and Afghanistan and the huge military bases that have been in Saudi Arabia since the Persian Gulf War, bases that people hate our guts for-- and you know, who knew? Who knew?
有人告诉我，在事情发生的第一周，她睡觉时都开着收音机，因为她不想错过任何可能会解释这一切为何发生的机会。你不觉得有这种感觉吗？无论过去两周我们对奥萨马·本·拉登、阿富汗以及自海湾战争以来一直驻扎在沙特阿拉伯的庞大军事基地了解多少——那些让人恨之入骨的基地——你知道，谁会想到呢？谁会想到呢？
No matter how many of these facts that we learn about why people in other countries hate us-- facts and facts and facts-- somehow in your gut, don't you have this feeling that it still just doesn't add up? It still does not make sense to you? So you know, we all keep trying.
无论我们学到多少关于其他国家的人为什么恨我们的事实——事实就是事实——不知何故，从内心深处，你不觉得这一切依然说不通吗？对你来说依然没有道理，对吧？所以你知道，我们都在继续努力。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Our Glass. Today on our program, stories about the news of the last two weeks. About what to make of things now that we've gone from what the world was before to what it is today. We have stories from David Sedaris, from David Rakoff, from Haruki Murakami and from others. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是关于过去两周的新闻报道。关于我们从之前的世界进入到今天的世界后，该如何看待这一切。我们有来自大卫·塞达里斯、大卫·拉科夫、村上春树和其他人的故事。请继续收听。
Act One. In the After of Before and After.
第一幕。在“之前”和“之后”的余波中。
Lynn Simpson is 50 and worked on the 89th floor of 1 World Trade Center for a small company called Strategic Communications, where the entire company was located in that building. They did marketing and communications for financial firms. And although she knows people who died in the attack on the building, the 20 or so people in her company all made it out. She escaped the building with about a minute to spare, and as the first tower collapsed, she was one of the people on the street who got showered with glass and debris and that huge cloud of dust and ash.
琳恩·辛普森今年 50 岁，在世贸中心一号大楼 89 楼一家名为“战略传播”的小公司工作，整家公司都在那栋楼里。他们为金融公司做营销和传播。虽然她认识在袭击中丧生的人，但她公司里的 20 多个人都逃出来了。她在第一座大楼倒塌时成功逃离，只比原定时间晚了一分钟，她和街上的人们一起被玻璃碎片、瓦砾以及巨大的尘埃烟云所覆盖。
She spoke with me from her apartment in Queens. I wanted to talk to her about what she's doing now, and especially what she makes of what happened to her. But we began by reviewing briefly how it is she made it to safety.
她从皇后区的公寓里和我通了话。我想和她谈谈她现在在做什么，尤其是她如何看待发生在自己身上的事情。但我们先简单回顾了她是怎样安全逃生的。
Well, there were five of us in the office. We were the early birds. And all of a sudden, there was an enormous crash. And the building actually-- it shook. We could feel it shake. The lights went out. The sprinklers came on. The ceiling came down. The file cabinets fell. Everything started toppling. And smoke immediately filled the entire office.
嗯，办公室里有五个人。我们是早到的人。突然间，一声巨响传来。大楼真的——它摇晃了。我们能感觉到它在晃。灯灭了，喷淋系统启动了。天花板掉下来了，档案柜倒了。所有东西都开始倒塌。浓烟立刻充斥了整个办公室。
On the floor where you were, how many floors were you from where the airplane hit?
在你所在的楼层，离飞机撞击的楼层还有多少层？
I believe the airplane hit either just above or just about the 89th, 90th, 91st floor. The only reason that I'm here, partly, is because the airplane hit on the other side of the building. My office had a view Uptown of the Empire State Building and the Hudson River and the East River. The lights were out. It was smoky, it was dim, and it was getting very hot.
我相信飞机撞击的位置就在 89、90 或 91 楼的上方或附近。我之所以还在这里，部分原因是飞机撞在了大楼的另一侧。我的办公室可以看到上城的帝国大厦、哈德逊河和东河。灯灭了，烟雾缭绕，光线昏暗，而且变得非常热。
I did try it the emergency stairwell and that door was locked. And we drank water, we covered our noses, and I called my boss, my boyfriend, and my mother.
我试过紧急楼梯间，但门锁住了。我们喝了水，捂住鼻子，我分别给老板、男朋友和我母亲打了电话。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I said-- I said to all of them, I'm all right. I don't know what's happened, but I'm all right. And my mother and John, we know me the best-- could hear that my voice was shaking, and I was shaking, and I was afraid. And I told John, I said, the doors are locked. I can't get out. I can't get down the stairway.
我说——我对他们所有人说，我没事。我不知道发生了什么，但我没事。我母亲和约翰——他们最了解我——能听出我的声音在颤抖，我也在颤抖，我感到害怕。我告诉约翰，我说，门锁住了。我出不去。我下不了楼梯。
A few minutes after that, people knocked on the door, and there were people, men with flashlights, knocking on the door, saying, come out and let's go downstairs. And the doors were opened at that point in time.
几分钟后，有人在敲门，是拿着手电筒的人在敲门，说，出来吧，我们下楼去。那时候门才开了。
The stairwell that you hadn't been able to get into.
就是你之前无法进入的那个楼梯间。
That I had tried before. But then we started down. And about the 83rd floor, we had to cross over. And we crossed over. That floor was devastated. It was pitch black. Full of smoke. The sprinklers were coming down. The ceiling had come down. We had to hold hands to walk across it. And the only light we basically had was one man's cell phone. And we made our way across that to another stairwell.
我之前试过的那个。但随后我们开始下楼。在大约 83 楼，我们需要换楼梯。我们换了过去。那一层已经彻底毁了。漆黑一片，全是烟。喷淋装置在往下流水，天花板塌了。我们必须手牵手走过去。我们唯一的照明基本上是一个人的手机。我们穿过那里到达了另一个楼梯间。
And then we proceeded down, I believe, to 78. At 78, we had to cross to another set of stairs. And when we crossed on 78, it was as if nothing had happened. The lights were on. No smoke. Air conditioning, carpeting, it was all perfect.
然后我们继续往下走，我想到了 78 楼。在 78 楼，我们不得不换到另一组楼梯。当我们穿过 78 楼时，感觉就像什么都没发生过一样。灯亮着，没有烟。空调、地毯，一切都完美无缺。
How strange. That must've been so strange for you all.
真奇怪。这对你们所有人来说一定很奇怪。
It was very peculiar. Very peculiar to go from one extreme to the other. But at 78, we had to make a decision. There were two exit signs. And one, I've since learned that one exit went down to one floor and then stopped. It was just dead. And the other exit, which somebody said, trust me. I know we have to go down this staircase. And we did. We trusted that person and we went down that staircase. And that led us to the bottom.
非常特别。从一个极端到另一个极端的感觉非常奇怪。但在 78 楼，我们必须做出决定。有两个出口标志。其中一个，我后来才知道，那个出口只通向下一层就中断了，是死路一条。另一个出口，有人说，“相信我，我知道我们得走这个楼梯。”我们照做了。我们相信了那个人，走下了那个楼梯。那把我们带到了底层。
And then we continued down. We had to move over to the side, because the firemen, in full gear, were coming up. And they started, they met us at about 50, and they started coming up.
然后我们继续下行。我们必须移到旁边，因为全副武装的消防员正在往上冲。他们在 50 楼左右迎面遇到我们，然后开始向上跑。
And when we got to the plaza level-- the plaza level is the level between the two towers. And there's a fountain out there, and they often use it for concerts. They told us, do not look up. Do not look out. Do not look down. Just keep going. And we need you to hurry. Run. Could you jog?
当我们到达广场层时——广场层是两座塔楼之间的层级。那里有一个喷泉，经常用来举办音乐会。他们告诉我们：不要向上看。不要向外看。不要向下看。一直往前走。我们需要你们快点。跑起来。能跑快点吗？
I'm sure that in the last week and a half, you must have thought a lot about the fact that you made it and a lot of other people didn't.
我肯定在过去的一周半里，你一定想过很多关于你逃脱而其他人没有逃脱的事实。
Yes.
是的。
What do you think when you think about that? How are you putting that together in your head?
你想到这些时在想什么？你在脑海里是怎么整合这些念头的？
A lot of it has to do, I think, with timing, with luck. There's a small part of me that feels that it was fated. Perhaps there's something else in the world that I'm supposed to do. I don't know. Part of me does feel that, definitely.
我觉得这很大程度上与时机、运气有关。有一小部分我觉得这是命中注定。也许世界上还有我应该做的事情。我不知道。我确实有一部分是这样想的。
But part of you feels like it's just chance.
但你有一部分觉得这仅仅是偶然。
Part of me feels like it's chance. I do know that my outlook on life has changed. I know that for me, I'm going to not put off things that I want to do. One of the things that is important to me is horseback riding. It's been important to me since I was seven. And John and I also live in Pennsylvania. And I told the next door neighbor, who is interested in horses, to please go out and find me two horses.
有一部分我觉得是偶然。我确实知道我的人生观改变了。我知道对于我来说，我不会再推迟想做的事情。我重要的事情之一是骑马。这从我七岁起就很重要。约翰和我也住在宾夕法尼亚州。我告诉邻居——她对马感兴趣——请帮我找两匹马。
And I also want to spend more time with my family, with my friends. They also sat with the minister-- my sister called the minister-- and they all sat in my mother's living room and, as they said, they watched me die as 1 World Trade Center went down. Because they hadn't heard from me since that nine o'clock phone call. And they said they grieved for about half an hour, until John called and said, I heard from Lynn and she's alive.
我还想花更多时间陪家人、陪朋友。他们也和牧师坐在一起——我姐姐给牧师打了电话——他们都坐在我母亲的客厅里，正如他们所说的，当世贸中心一号大楼倒塌时，他们眼睁睁看着我死去。因为自从九点钟那个电话后，他们就没收到我的消息。他们说他们哀悼了大约半个小时，直到约翰打电话说，我收到琳恩的消息了，她还活着。
Wow. So for half an hour, they thought you were gone.
哇。所以有半个小时，他们以为你不在了。
Yes. And John also thought I was gone, because he watched the towers go down. And nobody had heard from me. It was impossible to call.
是的。约翰也以为我不在了，因为他看着大楼倒塌。没人能联系上我。打不通电话。
Where did you finally call them from?
你最终是从哪里给他们打电话的？
I called them, I was walking across the Williamsburg Bridge and there were two guys walking to my left. And everybody kind of looked at me, because everybody walking with me looked normal. They had obviously been evacuated from their buildings and were leaving the city. I did not look normal. I was dust-covered, filthy, and staring straight ahead.
我给他们打电话时，正走过威廉斯堡大桥，左边有两个人在走。大家都盯着我看，因为和我一起走的人看起来都很正常。他们显然是从各自的大楼疏散出来的，正在离开城市。我看起来不正常。我浑身是灰，又脏又乱，直视前方。
And they asked me. They heard my story. And he had a cell phone.  And I said, may I please use your cell phone? He said, yes. I'm having trouble getting through, but you may use it. So I punched in the number, called John. I did it twice. It didn't go through. He kept hitting redial and redial for about five minutes, and he kept talking as we walked. And all of a sudden he got-- he said, it's ringing, and he handed me the phone.
他们问了我。他们听了我的故事。他正好有一部手机。我说，请问我能用一下你的手机吗？他说，可以。信号不好，但你可以用。我拨了号码，打给约翰。我打了两次。没接通。他大约五分钟里一直在按重拨，我们边走边聊。突然他接通了——他说，通了，电话响了，然后他把电话递给了我。
And I got on the phone, and I said, hi, John. I'm walking across a bridge. And John just screamed. And he told me that he fell on the floor. And he said, you're alive, you're alive, my God, you're alive. And I said, I'm alive. I'm walking across the Williamsburg Bridge. Please call my mother.
我拿起电话说，嗨，约翰。我正走在桥上。约翰直接尖叫起来。他告诉我他瘫倒在地上。他说，你活着，你活着，天哪，你还活着。我说，我还活着。我正走过威廉斯堡大桥。请给妈妈打电话。
Anybody who's been watching TV has seen the images of the Towers being hit and collapsing over and over and over. So you must have been seeing that as well.
任何看过电视的人都一遍又一遍地看到了塔楼被撞击和倒塌的画面。所以你一定也看到了。
Yes, I saw it. I did decide to watch it. And I did decide to watch it on Wednesday, the day after. I did not watch it on Tuesday night.
是的，我看到了。我决定看一看。我决定在周三，即事发后第二天看。周二晚上我没看。
And when you first saw what it was and what it looked like from outside, what did you think?
当你第一次看到外面是什么样子时，你有什么想法？
I was horrified. At the first plane that went in, I counted the floors. And I know that it went in very near my floor. On my floor.  It impacted the floor.
我很恐惧。在第一架飞机撞进去时，我数了楼层。我知道它撞击的位置非常靠近我所在的楼层。就是我那一层。撞击了那个楼层。
Does it seem more horrible watching the pictures of it and seeing it from the outside than it seemed when you were inside?
从外面看影像和画面，比你在内部时感觉更恐怖吗？
Yes. It seems much more horrible from the outside. Because inside, I don't have those images. I have my own images of smoke and flames and dust. But I don't have the image of-- I mean-- of the plane.
是的。从外面看要恐怖得多。因为在内部时，我没有那些画面。我有我自己关于浓烟、火焰和尘埃的画面。但我没有关于——我的意思是——关于那架飞机的画面。
And also, I cannot watch the TV with all of the missing people. That truly breaks my heart. And the tears well up.
而且，我无法观看电视上所有关于失踪人员的报道。那真的让我心碎。眼泪会涌出来。
Because you feel like, oh, that could have been your family.
因为你觉得，噢，那可能是你的家人。
Yes. It could have been my family. The fact that John was grieving here in New York and my family was grieving in Pennsylvania with the minister, and they were mourning me because they thought I was dead-- I mean, I can picture that. I can picture them all in their individual places, just mourning me. And my brother packed a black suit, a black tie, and white shirt, and drove to my mother's from New Jersey when he heard. Because he felt that he was going to be going to a funeral or memorial.
是的。那可能是我的家人。约翰在纽约悲痛欲绝，我的家人在宾夕法尼亚州和牧师在一起，因为他们以为我死了而在哀悼我——我的意思是，我能想象那种情景。我能想象他们每个人在各自的地方哀悼我。我哥哥听到消息后，打包了一套黑色西装、黑色领带和白衬衫，从新泽西州开车到我母亲那里。因为他觉得自己要去参加葬礼或追悼会。
And are you sleeping OK?
你现在睡得好吗？
Not really. No, not really. I do wake up a lot. And I try and put images out of my mind and go back to sleep. But it's hard. For the first several nights, I would wake up in the middle of the night and just have those images of the Towers in my mind, and the smoke.
不太好。不，真的不太好。我确实经常醒来。我试图把画面从脑海中赶走，然后继续睡。但很难。最初的几个晚上，我会在半夜醒来，脑海里满是塔楼和烟雾的画面。
And also, that was when I couldn't get the smell out of my hair. The very acrid dust smell. And I just had to get rid of that smell. And it's a smell that I will never forget. And it's a smell that's on my clothes. I have the clothes that I was wearing that day-- my shoes, my socks, my slacks, my top. Even the little, I wear a little thing in my hair which keeps my hair clipped back. And I don't know what to do with them.
还有，那是我的头发里一直散不去那种味道的时候。那种刺鼻的尘土味。我必须摆脱那种味道。那是我永远不会忘记的味道。那是我衣服上的味道。我还留着那天穿的衣服——鞋子、袜子、长裤、上衣。甚至那个小东西，我头发上夹着用来固定头发的小夹子。我不知道该怎么处理它们。
You still have them?
你还留着它们？
I still have them. I don't know what to do with them. I don't want to throw them away. I don't want to have them cleaned.
我还留着。我不知道该怎么办。我不想扔掉它们。我不想把它们拿去干洗。
Why don't you want to throw them away or have them cleaned?
为什么你不想扔掉它们或者拿去干洗？
I don't know. It's-- I don't know. I just can't quite let go of them. It is a bunch of trash. But it happened to me, and I survived. I just know that I have them in a bag and I keep the bag in a little corner. And I will eventually do something with them, because that's clutter, and clutter is not good. But right now, I just can't do that.
我不知道。这是——我不知道。我只是无法完全放手。那只是一堆垃圾。但那是发生在我身上的事，我幸存下来了。我只知道我把它们装在一个袋子里，放在一个小角落里。我最终会处理它们的，因为那是杂物，杂物不好。但现在，我就是做不到。
You know, when you talk about the World Trade Center, you do it in the present tense, as if it's still there. You talk about, there is a fountain, you know--
你知道，当你说到世贸中心时，你用的是现在时，就好像它还在那里。你说，有一个喷泉，你知道——
Yes, yes. I know.
是的，是的。我知道。
Do you feel like you fully accept that it really happened, that the buildings aren't there?
你觉得你是否完全接受了这件事真的发生了，建筑已经不在了？
Well, I accept it because I have crossed the George Washington Bridge and seen that they're not there. That's the reality. But no. It's almost-- it's surreal. It's not real. It's hard to believe that it's not there. Hard to believe I'm not going to go to work tomorrow.
好吧，我接受了，因为我过乔治华盛顿大桥时看到它们已经不在了。那是事实。但没有。这几乎——是超现实的。这不是真实的。很难相信它不在了。很难相信我明天不用去上班了。
So you haven't gone to work in a week and a half, right?
所以你已经一个半星期没去上班了，对吧？
No. Have not. There's no place to go at the moment. The company is going to try and start up again. They are leasing space and looking for computers. Because everything was there in that one office.
没有。还没去。目前没地方可去。公司打算重新开始。他们正在租赁空间并寻找电脑。因为所有的东西都在那个办公室里。
All your records, all your billing, everything.
你所有的记录、所有的账单，所有的一切。
Absolutely everything.
绝对是一切。
People owe you money.
人们还欠你的钱。
Yes.
是的。
But you have no idea who they are or how much they owe.
但你根本不知道他们是谁，或者欠多少钱。
That's right. That's true. And we owe people money.
没错。那是真的。而且我们也欠别人的钱。
And then how does that work? Is it some sort of insurance paying for your salary?
那该怎么处理？是有某种保险支付你的工资吗？
Well, it's two things. They they did receive an insurance payment
嗯，有两件事。他们确实收到了保险赔付。
Your firm?
你的公司？
My firm, yep. And so they are paying people. The first thing they did was to pay salaries. And the second thing they did was to tell everybody to go out and buy a computer and a printer, and they're going to get everybody company cell phones. Because the company-- they're very anxious to get back to work.
我的公司，是的。所以他们在给大家发工资。他们做的第一件事是支付薪水。第二件事是告诉大家去买电脑和打印机，他们会给每个人配公司手机。因为公司——他们非常渴望回去工作。
And if I could have bought a computer today, I would have gone out to buy one. But unfortunately, in the New York area, it's very difficult, if not impossible, to find a computer.
如果我今天能买到电脑，我会去买的。但不幸的是，在纽约地区，想找到一台电脑非常困难，甚至是不可能的。
Oh, because all the ones have been bought up by these businesses to restart.
噢，因为所有的电脑都被这些要重启业务的公司买光了。
They've been bought up. Every laptop, every desktop has been bought up.
都被买光了。每一台笔记本电脑、每一台台式机都被抢购一空。
When do you think you're going to want to go back to work?
你觉得你什么时候会想回去工作？
Well, I don't know. Probably next week or the week after.
嗯，我不知道。大概下周或下下周。
When you get up in the morning, do you think, oh wait, go to go somewhere, but you don't know where to go?
早上起床时，你会不会想，噢等等，得去哪儿，但你不知道去哪儿？
Yeah, I'm a little startled sometimes when I wake up in the morning. Because I don't set the alarm clock.
是的，有时候早上醒来会有点吃惊。因为我没定闹钟。
Are you flying a flag?
你在挂国旗吗？
Oh yes. And the flags are very heartwarming to see. It just makes me happy.  It makes me smile.
噢，是的。看到国旗让人倍感温暖。它让我快乐。它让我微笑。
I was wondering. When you see a flag, do you feel like it's the rest of us saying to you, you know, you barely made it out and other people's lives are touched in various ways, that we're with you? Like, our hearts are with you?
我在想。当你看到国旗时，你会不会觉得那是我们其余人在对你说，你知道，你勉强逃了出来，其他人的生活也受到了各种影响，我们和你在一起？就像，我们的心和你在一起？
Yes. And we're together.
是的。我们在一起。
And you're actually feeling it that way. That it's a message from us, to everyone, to you, who just got out, and all the other people whose lives have been touched.
你确实是这样感受的。觉得那是从我们这里传达给每个人的信息，传达给你这种刚逃出来的人，以及所有生活受到影响的人。
Yes. I do. And it's so many lives that have been touched. It's a good feeling. And it makes me feel as if we're putting aside petty differences and petty things that we all deal with on a day-to-day basis and get annoyed about and are uniting. And it's crossing political parties. It's crossing religious barriers. It's crossing everything. And that's everybody working together.
是的。我是这么觉得。而且有那么多人受到影响。这是一种好的感觉。这让我觉得我们正在放下琐碎的差异和日常生活中我们都会处理并感到烦恼的琐事，正在团结起来。这超越了政党。这超越了宗教障碍。这超越了一切。这就是大家共同努力。
Do you want revenge?
你想要报复吗？
No. I think that we, in America, need to understand why America and its way of life is hated so much by so many people. And I think that we need to protect ourselves and our shores and our people before there is retaliation.
不。我认为我们美国人需要理解为什么美国及其生活方式被这么多人如此憎恨。我认为我们需要在报复之前保护好我们自己、我们的海岸和我们的人民。
Is there a part of you which feels like, you know, don't do this for me. Like, I was in that building. Don't do it for me.
有没有一部分的你觉得，你知道，不要为了我这样做。就像，我曾经在那栋楼里。不要为了我这样做。
Yes. I feel like-- this was not a personal attack on me. It was an attack on America.
是的。我觉得——这并不是针对我个人的袭击。这是针对美国的袭击。
Yeah. Well said.
是啊。说得好。
It's not personal. I was an innocent bystander. The people who died were innocent victims. And what I'm saying is, we should not go and retaliate against other innocent victims. It cannot be indiscriminate bombing of Afghanistan or Pakistan or Saudi Arabia or any of those other places. It cannot be. That is not right. That should not be what we do.
这不是个人的事。我是无辜的旁观者。死去的人是无辜的受害者。我想说的是，我们不应该去报复其他无辜的受害者。不能是不分青红皂白地轰炸阿富汗、巴基斯坦、沙特阿拉伯或任何其他地方。不能这样。那是不对的。那不应该是我们所做的事。
Lynn Simpson in Queens, New York.
琳恩·辛普森，来自纽约皇后区。
Act Two. Watching From the River's Edge.
第二幕。从河岸边观察。
Trying to make sense of what has happened, we have turned for solace and understanding and perspective to look at how people have struggled with other urban disasters. One of our regular contributors, David Rakoff, lives in Manhattan, and tells the story of one that touched a neighborhood close to where he lives.
为了理解所发生的一切，我们在寻找安慰、理解和视角时，审视了人们在过去是如何与城市灾难抗争的。我们的一位常驻撰稿人大卫·拉科夫住在曼哈顿，他讲述了一个触及他住所附近街区的故事。
Near the north end of Tompkins Square Park in the East Village, a memorial fountain still stands. Erected by the Sympathy Society of German Ladies, it commemorates the fire aboard the steamship the General Slocum in 1904. The conflagration claimed the lives of 1,031 people, mostly women and children from what was then the German immigrant enclave known as Kleindeutschland. A sign near the fountain calls the fire "the worst disaster in the history of New York." In the most painful and horrifying example of this great city's capacity to top itself and exceed all previous expectations, the sign will now have to be changed.
在东村汤普金斯广场公园北端附近，至今矗立着一座纪念喷泉。它由德国妇女同情协会建立，纪念 1904 年“斯洛克姆将军号”蒸汽船上的火灾。那场大火夺走了 1,031 人的生命，他们主要是来自当时被称为“小德国”的德国移民区的妇女和儿童。喷泉旁的一块牌子称那场火灾为“纽约历史上最严重的灾难”。在这个伟大城市不断自我超越、超出所有预期的一系列最痛苦、最可怕的案例中，这块牌子现在不得不更换了。
It was on June 15, 1904, by all accounts a perfect day, that some 1,300 members of St. Mark's Evangelical Lutheran Church boarded the General Slocum at the 3rd Street Pier for their annual summer picnic. At 9:40 AM, the steamer, named for the Civil War hero Henry J. Slocum began on its way, passing under the Brooklyn Bridge, a mere 21 years old at the time, and headed north, up the East River, to a picnic ground on Long Island Sound.
那是 1904 年 6 月 15 日，据各方记载那是一个完美的一天，圣马可福音路德教会的约 1,300 名成员在第三街码头登上了“斯洛克姆将军号”，准备参加一年一度的夏季野餐。上午 9:40，这艘以南北战争英雄亨利·J·斯洛克姆命名的汽船启航，穿过当时仅有 21 年历史的布鲁克林大桥，向北沿着东河驶往长岛海峡的一个野餐点。
In the days after the disaster, a minute-by-minute account of what happened on the steamboat was pieced together. At 9:57 AM, a boy noticed smoke seeping from underneath the door of the lower forward cabin. Among the preparations made for the day had been three barrels filled with drinking glasses packed in hay that were stowed there. A discarded match had started them smouldering.
在灾难发生后的几天里，人们拼凑出了汽船上所发生事情的每分钟记录。上午 9:57，一名男孩注意到烟雾从下前舱的门下渗出。当天的一项准备工作是存放在那里的三个装满用干草包裹的饮用玻璃杯的桶。一根丢弃的火柴引发了它们的阴燃。
At 10 AM, an inexperienced deckhand opened the door and the embers burst into flames, which spread through the lower hallways and lounges, triggering the panicked escape of the terrified passengers. Another boy ran to tell the captain, William Van Schaick. "Get the hell out of here and mind your own business," he replied, thinking it a prank. He didn't realize it was true until six minutes later, when he looked out his cabin and saw the flames and the burning passengers. By this time it was too late.
上午 10 点，一名毫无经验的甲板工打开了门，余烬爆发成火焰，蔓延到下层走廊和休息室，引发了惊恐的乘客的恐慌逃离。另一名男孩跑去告诉威廉·范·斯查克船长。船长以为这是恶作剧，回答道：“滚一边去，管好你自己的事。”直到六分钟后，当他看向船舱并看到火焰和燃烧的乘客时，他才意识到这是真的。此时已为时已晚。
The spanking seaworthiness of the Slocum, newly painted and festooned with bunting and flags, was a fiction. The hold was littered with debris. The crew was new and largely untrained and had never practiced a single fire drill. The fire hose, deployed far too late, was useless anyway, the linen having rotted through and splitting along its length immediately.
“斯洛克姆号”光鲜亮丽的适航性——新刷的油漆、装饰着彩旗和旗帜——不过是一个虚构。船舱里到处都是垃圾。船员大多是新招聘的，且基本未受过训练，从未进行过任何消防演习。远未及时部署的消防水龙带也是无用的，亚麻布早已腐烂，沿缝裂开。
The lifeboats had been painted fast to the railings of the boat, and what life jackets this could be pulled free from the overhead mesh were over 13 years old. Some tore open like the hose, showering the heads of people with the crumbs of their disintegrated cork filling. Other life jackets held together, but they proved lethal. A woman dropped her daughter over the side wearing one, only to watch her sink like a stone.
救生艇被漆死在船的栏杆上，而那些能从头顶网格中拉出的救生衣都已超过 13 年历史。有些像水龙带一样撕开了，里面的软木填料碎屑淋了人们一头一脸。其他的救生衣勉强支撑着，但却致命。一名妇女给女儿穿上救生衣后将她扔入水中，却眼睁睁看着她像石头一样沉下去。
All was pandemonium. From the shores of the Bronx and across the river in Queens, people watched, horrified at what was happening just 200 yards away. Some swam in to try and save the scores of people who jumped from the vessel, some on fire, some caught up in the ship's paddle wheels.
一切都是一片混乱。从布朗克斯海岸到对岸的皇后区，人们惊恐地看着距离仅 200 码处发生的一切。有些人跳入水中，试图挽救那些从船上跳下的人，有的身上带着火，有的被船的桨轮卷入。
The General Slocum fully exploded into flames at 10:06, eventually coming to rest, a burning hulk, on North Brothers island at 10:10. It took less than a quarter of an hour. Among the 1,031 dead, not one crewman, nor the captain.
“斯洛克姆将军号”在 10:06 完全陷入火海，最终在 10:10 变成了一具燃烧的残骸停在北兄弟岛上。整个过程不到一刻钟。在 1,031 名死者中，没有一名船员，也没有船长。
There were hundreds of funerals that weekend in Kleindeutschland with miles long processions leading the hearses across the river to the Lutheran cemetery in Queens. The owners of the steamship company were prosecuted and fined. The captain, William Van Schaick, was convicted of negligence and manslaughter and sentenced to ten years in Sing Sing. He was paroled after three and a half and pardoned by William Howard Taft on Christmas day of 1911. The boat itself was, unbelievably, salvaged and converted into a cargo barge, which finally sank in the storm near Atlantic City that same year.
那个周末在“小德国”有数百场葬礼，送葬队伍跨过河水，绵延数英里前往皇后区的路德公墓。汽船公司的所有者被起诉并处以罚款。船长威廉·范·斯查克因过失杀人罪被判处十年有期徒刑，关押在胜胜监狱。他在三年半后获得假释，并于 1911 年圣诞节被威廉·霍华德·塔夫脱赦免。令人难以置信的是，这艘船本身被捞起并改建为货驳，最终在同一年在亚特兰大城附近的风暴中沉没。
Accounts of the horror of June 15 itself are many. There is also a well-preserved transcript of the inquest and trial. By contrast, there are almost no details of the emotional aftermath. The closest that I could find is a posting on the General Slocum website from a woman named Jacquelin Duffy who writes, "My father's family lived on East 5th Street, and according to him, there was not a tenement on that street that did not have at least one crepe at the doorway."
关于 6 月 15 日那天的恐怖记载有很多。还有一份保存完好的调查和审判记录。相比之下，几乎没有关于情感余波的细节。我能找到最接近的是“斯洛克姆将军号”网站上由一位名叫杰奎琳·达菲的女士发布的一篇帖子，她写道：“我父亲的家人住在东 5 街，据他说，那条街上没有一间公寓的门前不挂着至少一块绉纱。”
If the need to speak of calamity is human nature, we are also predisposed to suffering our lasting sorrows in silence. There is more than one posting on the website about families that never spoke of the day again. How does one articulate the ongoing sadness of after? An anguish so great that the only recourse for people was to leave forever the buildings and streets that now only held memories of death?
如果谈论灾难是人类的天性，我们也倾向于默默忍受持久的悲伤。网站上不止一个帖子提到，有些家庭从此再也没有谈论过那一天。如何表达这种延续的“之后”的悲伤？这种痛苦如此巨大，以至于人们唯一的求生之道就是永远离开那些现在只承载死亡记忆的建筑和街道。
The articles about the General Slocum almost all end the same way. That Kleindeutschland was never the same afterwards. That's the term they use. "Never the same." The German community uprooted itself, resettling on the Upper East Side and in Queens. Some men simply moved back to Germany.
关于“斯洛克姆将军号”的文章几乎都以同样的方式结尾。那个“小德国”之后就再也不一样了。这就是他们用的词。“再也不一样了。”德国社区向外迁移，重新安置在上东区和皇后区。有些人干脆搬回了德国。
What seems to have scattered the survivors was despair, not economics. The dead were, for the most part, not breadwinners. They were women, grandparents, and children. Half of the victims were under 20 years old.
看来导致幸存者流散的是绝望，而不是经济原因。死者大部分不是家庭的经济支柱。他们是妇女、祖父母和儿童。一半的受害者不到 20 岁。
Today there are bedroom communities on Long Island and the New Jersey-- Manhasset, Montclair, Ridgewood, Summit-- that are missing hundreds of parents, neighbors, and friends. Entire ladder companies of fire stations are gone. Right now, we New Yorkers are being told that our spirits are not broken. That we will rebuild, and we will do it quickly. We would do well to remember, in this time of stalwart rhetoric, that for some people, rebuilding will be harder. It's not for us to say.
今天在长岛和新泽西——曼哈塞特、蒙特克莱尔、里奇伍德、萨米特——都有一些睡城，那里缺失了数百名父母、邻居和朋友。整个消防站的梯队都不见了。现在，我们纽约人被告知我们的精神没有被打垮。我们将重建，而且会很快。我们应该记住，在这个充满坚定言辞的时刻，对于一些人来说，重建会更加困难。这不是我们该说的。
If there is a difference in the immediacy of the experience right now between New York City and the rest of the country, there is a far more profound separation within the city itself. Between the people directly affected by the terror and those not. I can count myself lucky to be among the latter, essentially untouched and never more superfluous in my adoptive city than right now. Beyond donating blood or money, I am of about as much use as a Belgian chocolate.
如果纽约市和全国其他地区目前在体验的直接性上存在差异，那么在城市内部本身，这种分离就深刻得多。发生在直接受恐怖影响的人和未受影响的人之间。我可以算作幸运的，属于后者，本质上没受影响，在这一刻，在我收留我的城市里，我感到前所未有的多余。除了捐血或捐款，我基本上就像一块比利时巧克力一样没用。
The memorial fountain is a nine foot tall slab of pink Tennessee marble, now quite white with age. In relief are the heads of two children, round-cheeked, angelic in profile, a blossoming branch framing them. "They were earth's purest children, young and fair," it says on the front. About three feet off the ground, a marble lion's head shoots forth a stream of drinking water. If one didn't work around to the side to read the memorial inscription, which has faded with the years, one might easily mistake this fountain for a municipal nicety, its image of the children and the words about them nothing more than a turn-of-the-century paean to the innocence of childhood, perfectly suited to a park where families might take a stroll.
那座纪念喷泉是一块九英尺高的粉红色田纳西大理石板，由于年代久远现在显得相当苍白。浮雕是两个孩子的头像，脸颊圆润，侧影如天使，一根盛开的树枝衬托着他们。“他们是世上最纯洁的孩子，年轻而美丽，”正面这样写道。离地约三英尺处，一个大理石狮子头喷出一股饮用水。如果一个人没有走到侧面去读那段已经随着岁月褪色的纪念碑文，很容易就会把这个喷泉误认为是一个城市的装饰品，孩子们和对他们的评价只不过是对童年纯真的一种世纪之交的赞歌，非常适合家庭散步的公园。
There are countless makeshift altars to Tuesday the 11th all over the city. Clusters of votive candles, flowers, and a heartbreaking, staggering number of fliers with photographs and names of the missing. Tompkins Square Park is no exception, but curiously, there is nothing around the fountain. No one seems to have remembered the fearful symmetry of this spot.
全城到处都是 11 日那个周二的简易祭坛。一簇簇的许愿蜡烛、鲜花，还有令人心碎、数量惊人的失踪者照片和名字的传单。汤普金斯广场公园也不例外，但奇怪的是，喷泉周围什么都没有。似乎没人想起这个地点的可怕对称性。
A block away is St. Mark's Lutheran, the church of the Slocum 's victims. It is now an Orthodox synagogue, and it is the first day of the Jewish New Year when I walk by. A boy, about eight, runs down the steps and gives a holler. His father comes out after him and calls, "Wait up!" He says it like a schoolyard pal. The boy stops, and his father catches up with him, and they continue down the block.
一街之隔就是圣马可路德教堂，“斯洛克姆号”受害者的教堂。它现在是一座东正教犹太会堂，当我走过时正是犹太新年的第一天。一个大约八岁的男孩跑下台阶大喊了一声。他父亲追在他后面叫道：“等等！”他说得就像学校里的伙伴。男孩停了下来，他父亲追上他，他们继续沿着街走下去。
If you didn't know, it would seem like a perfect day. But of course, you do know, and cannot imagine a day when you won't. Perhaps the only comfort to be taken in all of this, and it is a cold one, is that such a day will come. Such a day is inevitable.
如果你不知道，这看起来就像一个完美的日子。但当然，你是知道的，而且无法想象会有哪一天你不知道。也许这一切中唯一能得到的慰藉——虽然是一种冷酷的慰藉——就是那一天终会到来。那一天是不可避免的。
David Rakoff in New York. He's the author of the book Fraud.
大卫·拉科夫在纽约。他是《欺诈》一书的作者。
Act Three. Notes From the Underground.
第三幕。来自地下室的笔记。
On our search for events that might somehow eliminate what we've see in New York this week, the staff of the radio show came across a book by the Japanese fiction writer Haruki Murakami. He went out and interviewed survivors of a terrorist attack that happened in a fantastically crowded city during rush hour just six years ago. On March 20, 1995, a radical doomsday cult called Aum Shinrikyo dropped plastic bags of poison gas on the Tokyo subway. The kind of gas they used was called sarin. It is reportedly 26 times as potent as cyanide gas. Over 5,000 people were injured. 12 died.
为了寻找某种可能消除我们本周在纽约所见所闻的事件，电台节目的工作人员偶然发现了日本小说家村上春树的一本书。他走出去采访了六年前在高峰时段一个极其拥挤的城市里遭受恐怖袭击的幸存者。1995 年 3 月 20 日，一个名为“奥姆真理教”的激进末日邪教在东京地铁投下了装有毒气的塑料袋。他们使用的那种气体被称为“沙林”。据报道，它的毒性是氰化物的 26 倍。超过 5,000 人受伤，12 人死亡。
Murakami interviewed dozens of survivors about what happened and how they got on with their lives afterwards. The English edition of the book is called Underground: the Tokyo Gas Attack in the Japanese Psyche, and he gave us permission to re portions of it here. You'll hear a number of different voices representing different interviewees.
村上采访了数十名幸存者，了解他们当时的情况以及事后如何生活。该书的英文版名为《地下：东京地铁毒气袭击与日本灵魂》，他授权我们在此转载部分内容。你将听到代表不同受访者的不同声音。
I left the house as usual, just after seven. But as luck would have it, the bus was about two minutes early. It was always late, but for once, it was ahead of schedule. I ran for the stop but didn't make it in time, so I had to catch the next bus at 7:30 instead. Looking back, it all started because the bus was two minutes early.
我和往常一样七点多离开家。但幸运的是，那班车早到了两分钟。它平时总是晚点，但那天破天荒地超前了。我跑去车站但没赶上，所以不得不坐 7:30 的下一班车。回想起来，这一切都是因为那班车早到了两分钟。
I looked up to see this man sitting directly to my left wearing a leather coat. I was still wrapped up in my book, but it really began to get on my nerves. Leather coats often smell funny, don't they? A disinfectant or a nail polish remover kind of smell. This guy stinks, I thought. And I stared him right in the eye. Only he doesn't seem to be looking at me. He just stared back at me with this, you've got a problem, mister? kind of look. He's looking past me to something on my right.
我抬头看到左侧坐着那个穿着皮衣的男人。我还在看书，但这真让我恼火。皮衣通常闻起来很怪，不是吗？一种消毒剂或指甲油卸妆水的味道。这人真臭，我想。我直视他的眼睛。但他似乎没看我。他只是回瞪着我，一副“你有什么问题吗，先生？”的表情。他正看着我右边的某个东西。
I turned around to look and saw something about the size of a notebook lying at the feet of the second person on my right. It's like a plastic pack. In the news they said it was wrapped in newspaper, but what I saw was plastic, and something spilling out of it.
我转过身看去，看到我右侧第二个人脚边放着一个笔记本大小的东西。那像是一个塑料包装。新闻里说它是用报纸包裹的，但我看到的是塑料，还有什么东西从里面漏出来。
That's when I got a sharp smell of isopropyl alcohol. We use the stuff for wiping clean the glass in our copiers, so I know it very well. I always carry it on the job.
那时候我闻到了一股刺鼻的异丙醇味。我们用这东西清理复印机里的玻璃，所以我非常熟悉。我工作中总是带着它。
It was somehow syrupy sweet. Not unpleasant at all. If it had smelled really bad, everyone would have been in a panic.
那味道不知怎么有一种糖浆般的甜味。一点也不令人不快。如果味道很臭，大家早就陷入恐慌了。
I felt a strange tickle in my throat. You know when your dentist gives you anesthetic and it's seeping back into your throat? Just like that.
我的喉咙感到一阵奇怪的刺痒。你知道当牙医给你打麻药，它渗进你喉咙时的感觉吗？就是那样。
So that's what's making the place smell, I thought. But I still just sat there. Soon everyone was saying, open the windows, it stinks. So they all opened the windows. I remember thinking, it's so cold. Can't you just put up with the smell?
所以我想，原来是这东西让这地方有味道的。但我还是坐在那儿。很快每个人都在说，开窗户，这儿太臭了。于是大家都打开了窗户。我记得当时想，这儿太冷了，你们不能忍忍味道吗？
I stood at the front, next to the driver's compartment, holding the handrail by the door. Then when I took a deep breath, I got this sudden pain. Really it was like I'd been shot or something. All of a sudden my breathing completely stopped. Like if I inhaled anymore, all of my guts would be spilling right out of my mouth. Everything became a vacuum.
我站在前头，驾驶舱旁边，扶着门边的扶手。然后当我深吸一口气时，突然感到一阵剧痛。真的就像我被枪击中了一样。突然间我的呼吸完全停止了。就像如果再吸一口气，我所有的内脏都会从嘴里喷出来。一切都变成了真空。
It seems kind of odd, but I thought, just maybe my granddad's died. He lived up north and was 94 years old at the time. I'd heard he'd been taken ill, so maybe this was a kind of sign. That was my first thought. Maybe he died or something.
这听起来有点奇怪，但我当时想，也许是我爷爷去世了。他住在北方，当时 94 岁。我听说他病了，所以也许这是某种征兆。这是我的第一个念头。也许他去世了什么的。
Then suddenly I heard a woman scream. A loud, piercing squawk like a parrot. At least I think it was a woman. It came from outside the car. What now? I thought. But the platform was so crowded, I couldn't see anything from inside the train.
然后我突然听到一个女人尖叫。像鹦鹉一样刺耳的尖叫声。至少我觉得是个女人。声音是从车厢外传来的。现在又是怎么了？我想。但站台上太拥挤了，我从车厢里什么也看不见。
Suddenly my eyesight went funny, as if I were seeing fireworks or something. Odd, I thought. Then ten seconds later, my eyes blacked out totally. It was a bright, clear day, then out of nowhere, this curtain descended and I couldn't see a thing.
突然我的视力变得很奇怪，好像看到烟花什么的。奇怪，我想。十秒钟后，我的眼睛完全黑了。明明是明亮晴朗的一天，然后凭空落下了一块帷幕，我什么也看不见了。
The train went above ground for awhile, and for some reason, the sky was dark, as if it were black and white, or sepia, just like an old photograph. That's odd, I thought. Today was supposed to be sunny.
列车在地面上行驶了一会儿，不知为何，天空是黑的，就像是黑白的，或者说是深褐色，就像旧照片一样。真奇怪，我想。今天应该很晴朗的。
My legs started to feel shaky. My eyes stopped working. Suddenly, it was as if night had fallen. Damn, I thought. I should've stayed back there with the others.
我的腿开始发抖。我的眼睛罢工了。突然间，仿佛夜晚降临了。该死，我想。我本该和别人留在后头的。
I moved from strapped to strap until I reached the pole near the door. Finally I stepped off the train, my hand out ready to catch myself at the far wall of the platform. I remember thinking, if I don't make it to the wall and crouch down, I'm going to fall and hit my head. Then I blanked out.
我抓着吊环挪到门边的杆子上。最后我走下列车，伸出手准备在站台远端的墙上稳住自己。我记得当时想，如果我不能摸到墙并蹲下，我就会摔倒撞到头。然后我就晕过去了。
Actually, I hadn't left the train. I grabbed the stainless steel pole and just slid down to the floor. What I thought was a wall was in fact the floor of the car, which felt chilly to my right hand. They ran a photo of me in the tabloids so I could see later what happened.
其实我没下车。我抓着不锈钢杆子直接滑到了地上。我以为是墙的东西实际上是车厢的地板，摸起来凉凉的。后来小报上登了我的照片，我才知道发生了什么。
I couldn't see. I couldn't run. It couldn't have been far, but I tripped on something and fell. I'm going to die like this, I thought. It'd be pathetic to die like this. When I was six, I nearly drowned swimming in a river, and I remember thinking, saved back then only to go blind and die like this? I just didn't want to die. Not there. Not like that.
我看不见。我跑不动。离得应该不远，但我被什么东西绊倒了。我会这样死掉吗，我想。这样死掉太可悲了。我六岁时在河里游泳差点溺水，记得当时想，那时候被救下来难道就是为了瞎了眼死在这儿？我只是不想死。不是在这儿。不是那样。
I phoned the office to tell them, I have to be hospitalized for I don't know how many days. I'm sorry to trouble you. But could you tidy up my desk?
我打电话给办公室说，我得住院，不知道要住多少天。给你们添麻烦了。你们能不能整理一下我的办公桌？
I'd been right at the epicenter. But instead of shuddering at the death toll, I felt like I was watching a program on TV. As if it were someone else's problem. It was only much later that I began to wonder how I could have been so callous. I ought to have been furious, ready to explode. It wasn't until the autumn that it really sank in, little by little.
我当时就在震中。但我不觉得惊恐，反而感觉像是在看电视节目。仿佛那是别人的问题。直到很久以后，我才开始纳闷我怎么能这么冷酷。我本该暴怒，随时会爆炸的。直到秋天才一点点意识到。
I'd just got back from a ten-day business trip to South America. Strange, you know. While I was in South America, I was invited out to karaoke by someone from the Japanese embassy in Colombia. Then I almost went back the next day to the same place. But I said, no, let's try somewhere new. And that very day, the place got bombed. I remember thinking when I got back home, at least Japan's a safe place. And the next day I go to work and the gas attack happens. What a joke.
我刚从南美洲的十天出差回来。奇怪，你知道。在南美时，日本驻哥伦比亚大使馆的人邀请我去唱卡拉 OK。第二天我本来差点又要去同一个地方。但我说，不，我们去别处吧。而就在那天，那个地方被炸了。我记得回家时想，至少日本是个安全的地方。结果第二天我去上班，毒气袭击就发生了。真是个笑话。
Afterwards I probably went a little funny in the head. I went around telling people, something's out there. You'll see. Something strange is going to happen. I was buying survival gear camping stores. After I came back to normal, I thought, what a fool I've been. But at the time, I was deadly serious. Now, what am I going to do with a survival knife?
后来我的大脑可能有点不正常。我到处跟人说，有什么东西在那儿。等着瞧吧。会发生什么奇怪的事情的。我在露营店买生存装备。恢复正常后，我想，我真是个傻瓜。但当时，我是无比认真的。现在，我拿生存刀干什么呢？
Right after the attack, I was insane with anger. I was pacing the hospital corners, pounding on the columns and walls. At that point, I still didn't know it was Aum. But whoever it was, I was ready to beat them up.
袭击刚过，我愤怒得发疯。我在医院角落里徘徊，捶打柱子和墙壁。那时候我甚至不知道是奥姆真理教干的。但不管是谁，我准备好要揍扁他们了。
I didn't even notice, but several days later, my fist was sore. I asked my wife, why does my hand hurt so much? And she said, you've been punching things, dear.
我甚至没注意到，几天后，我的拳头疼了。我问妻子，我的手为什么这么疼？她说，亲爱的，你一直在打东西。
Of course I was furious. But to tell the truth, stronger than any anger now is the feeling that I just don't want to remember anymore. Between the time I was hospitalized and the time I was sent home, I wanted to know everything that had happened. I was devouring the news on TV, but now I can't stand it. I changed the channel. I don't ever want to see another image of the gas attacks.
我当然愤怒。但说实话，现在比起任何愤怒，更强烈的感受是我根本不想再记起来了。从我住院到出院的那段时间，我想知道所有发生的事情。我狼吞虎咽地看电视新闻，但现在我受不了了。我换了频道。我再也不想看到任何关于毒气袭击的画面了。
The question I hate being asked most of all is, do you have any aftereffects? I just can't bear anyone asking me that. Although my dislike of being asked if there are aftereffects might itself be a kind of aftereffect.
我最恨被问的问题是，你有什么后遗症吗？我简直受不了有人问我这个。虽然我讨厌被问是否有后遗症，这本身可能就是一种后遗症。
I'd just like to know what the criminals thought they were doing. I demand a full explanation and an apology. I'd absolutely insist on it. I might easily have died there. I do you think about that. I'm still nervous going out alone. It's not even whether to take the subway. Just to go out walking scares me now.
我只想知道那些犯罪分子以为他们在做什么。我要求彻底的解释和道歉。我绝对坚持要道歉。我本可能轻而易举地死在那里。我确实会想那个。我现在独自出门还是很紧张。这不是该不该坐地铁的问题。现在连出门走走都让我害怕。
I live alone now, but at the time I had a family. A wife and kids. Sorry drag out the sordid details.
我现在一个人住，但当时我有家人。有妻子和孩子。抱歉把这些肮脏的细节讲出来。
To be honest, the day after the gas attack, I asked my wife for a divorce. We weren't on the best of terms at the time and I'd done my fair share of thinking. Still, even after all I'd been through, she would barely speak to me.
说实话，毒气袭击后的第二天，我就向妻子提出了离婚。那时我们关系并不好，我也思考良多。尽管如此，即使经历了这么多，她几乎还是不跟我说话。
After being gassed, I phoned home from the office to tell my wife what had happened and my symptoms and everything, but I got almost no reaction from her. Perhaps she couldn't really grasp the situation-- exactly what had occurred. But even so, I knew then that we'd come to a turning point. Or else the state I was in had gotten me all worked up.
中气后，我从办公室打电话回家告诉妻子发生了什么，我的症状以及一切，但她几乎没有反应。也许她无法真正理解当时的情况——到底发生了什么。但即便如此，我知道那时候我们到了一个转折点。或者是我所处的状态让我太过激动了。
Maybe that's what it was. Maybe that's why I came straight out with it and said, I wanted a divorce. Perhaps if the sarin thing hadn't happened, I wouldn't have been talking about divorce so soon. I probably wouldn't have said anything. It was a shock to the system, and at the same time, a kind of trigger.
也许就是那样。也许这就是为什么我直截了当地提出了离婚。如果沙林毒气那件事没发生，我可能不会这么快谈离婚。我可能什么都不会说。那不仅是对系统的冲击，同时也是一种触发。
My family had been in such a mess for so long that by then, I didn't consider myself very important. Not that the possibility of dying wasn't real. But had I died, I probably could have accepted it, in my own way, as just a kind of accident.
我的家庭陷入混乱太久了，以至于那时，我不觉得我自己很重要。并不是说死亡的可能性不真实。但如果我死了，我可能可以用我自己的方式接受它，就当是一场意外。
For a while after the gas attack I felt like throwing everything away. I'm generally good at holding onto things. I still have my plastic pencil case from elementary school. But I wanted to toss everything out. It was like nothing's worthwhile anymore. I even felt like giving away my most precious Bonsai.
毒气袭击后的一段时间，我感觉想把所有东西都扔掉。我通常很擅长保留东西。我小学时的塑料文具盒我还留着。但我当时想把一切都扔掉。感觉没什么东西再有价值了。我甚至想把最珍贵的盆栽送人。
After the gas attack, I had terrible nightmares. The one I remember best was a dream in which someone pulled me out of my bed next to the window and dragged me around the room. Or I turned and suddenly saw someone standing there who was supposed to be dead. Yeah, I often met dead people in my dreams.
毒气袭击后，我做了可怕的噩梦。我记得最深的一个梦是有人把我从窗边的床上拉出来，在房间里拖行。或者我转过身，突然看到一个本该死去的人站在那里。是的，我经常在梦里遇到死人。
Afterwards I wasn't scared to travel on the subway. No bad dreams, either. Maybe I'm just dull-witted and thick-skinned. But I do feel it was fate. Usually I don't go through the first door nearest the front. I always use to second, which would put me downwind of the sarin. But that day and that day only, I took the first door for no special reason. Pure chance.
后来我不怕坐地铁了。也没做噩梦。也许我只是反应迟钝、脸皮厚。但我确实觉得这是命中注定。通常我不走最靠近前头的门。我总是走第二扇，那会让我处于沙林的下风处。但那天，而且只有那天，我无缘无故地走了第一扇门。纯粹是偶然。
Excerpts from Haruki Murakami's interviews with survivors of the Tokyo gas attack collected in his book Underground. Our readers included Richard Henzel, [? Scott Jacques, ?] Jennifer Angstrom, Gary Brichetto, Richard Brown, Elizabeth Rich, Evelyn Friedman, Rick Peoples, Todd Bachmann, and Justin Kaufmann. Thanks to Chicago's Steppenwolf Theatre and to Erica Daniels for helping us find the readers.
节选自村上春树对东京毒气袭击幸存者的采访，收录于他的书《地下》中。我们的朗读者包括理查德·亨泽尔、斯考特·杰克、詹妮弗·安格斯通、加里·布里切托、理查德·布朗、伊丽莎白·里奇、伊芙琳·弗里德曼、里克·皮普斯、托德·巴赫曼和贾斯汀·考夫曼。感谢芝加哥斯泰彭沃尔夫剧院和埃里卡·丹尼尔斯帮助我们找到了这些朗读者。
Coming up. David Sedaris writes about the news. In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
稍后。大卫·塞达里斯谈论新闻。一分钟后，节目在国际公共广播电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose some topic, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that topic. Today's program, stories trying to make sense of things in the aftermath of the World Trade Center and Pentagon attacks, as our country heads towards war.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，是关于试图在世贸中心和五角大楼袭击的余波中理清思路的故事，此时我们的国家正走向战争。
We've arrived at act four our show. Act Four. Far From Home.
我们到达了节目的第四幕。第四幕。远离家乡。
David Sedaris lives in Paris, France with his boyfriend Hugh, which is where they've been following the news over the last two weeks.
大卫·塞达里斯和他的男友休住在法国巴黎，他们过去两周一直在那里跟踪新闻。
Living as a foreigner in another country, you learn that your welcome can turn on a single newspaper headline. Like the dollar, public opinion fluctuates between one extreme and another. So when the exchange is good, you try to stock up, knowing that tomorrow, anything could happen.
作为一个在另一个国家的外国人，你会了解到你的受欢迎程度可能因一个新闻标题而改变。就像美元一样，公众舆论在两个极端之间波动。所以当汇率好时，你要试着多储备一点，因为你知道明天什么都可能发生。
Hugh and I recently moved, and in the days following the attacks on New York and Washington, each of our new neighbors came to introduce themselves and offer their sympathy. Are your friends all right? Your family? Do you need anything? Shopkeepers heard my accent and sometimes went so far as to touch my hand-- a gesture no less shocking than a full-frontal bear hug. Businessmen and widows from the embassy offering their beds to Americans stuck at the airport. And at noon on the official day of mourning, pedestrians stopped in their path and cars pulled off the road to observe the three minutes of silence. I stored it up.
休和我最近刚搬家，在纽约和华盛顿遭袭后的那几天，我们的新邻居们纷纷登门介绍自己并表示同情。你的朋友还好吗？家人呢？需要什么吗？店主听到我的口音，甚至会握住我的手——这种姿态并不比一个正式的拥抱逊色。使馆的商人和遗孀们主动为被困在机场的美国人提供床位。在官方哀悼日的中午，行人停下脚步，车辆靠边停下，观察三分钟的沉默。我把这一切都记在心里。
People started leaving flowers in the little park across the street from the American embassy. And it was genuine until the TV cameras arrived, at which point it became self-conscious. The planes move in, the towers collapse, and people react with heartfelt shock and horror. You cry because you're sad and frightened, and then, before you know it, the images are repeated in slow motion with the Samuel Barber soundtrack and a close-up photograph of a singed Teddy bear. Then you cry because somebody's making you, and you wind up feeling confused and manipulated, like your own feelings weren't quite good enough, and you needed professional help.
人们开始在离美国大使馆对面的小公园里放置鲜花。在摄像机到来之前，这是真诚的，但随后变得矫揉造作。飞机冲进去，塔楼倒塌，人们反应出由衷的震惊和恐惧。你因为悲伤和恐惧而哭泣，然后不知不觉中，这些图像被配上塞缪尔·巴伯的配乐进行慢动作回放，并加上一张烧焦泰迪熊的特写照片。于是你哭是因为有人在逼你哭，最后你感到困惑和被操纵，好像你自己的感觉还不够好，你需要专业帮助。
Two days after the attack, my friend Kristin and I attended a service at the American Church. Unlike the service held the previous afternoon at the American Cathedral, this was a media event, attended by the mayor of Paris, the prime minister, and President Chirac. The church was small and half the pews were cordoned off for members of parliament and the American diplomatic corps, who swept in from the rain under heavy security. The line for the rest of us stretched around the corner and down the street, and for every American, there were two journalists with cameras and microphones asking how we felt The instinct was to say that oh, aside from a slight sore throat, you felt pretty good, but of course, you just couldn't.
袭击发生两天后，我的朋友克里斯汀和我参加了美国教会的一次仪式。与前一天下午在美国大教堂举行的仪式不同，这是一场媒体活动，巴黎市长、总理和希拉克总统都出席了。教堂很小，一半的座位被隔开给议会议员和美国外交使团，他们在大雨中在严密的安保下入场。剩下的我们排起的长队绕过了街角延伸到街上，而每有一个美国人，就有两名带着相机和麦克风的记者询问我们的感受。本能是想说，噢，除了喉咙有点痛，我感觉还行，但当然，你根本没法那么说。
The service was broadcast on television, so although it was an American church, the sermon was delivered in French with short speeches given by a minister, a rabbi, and a Muslim cleric. It was all very tasteful, but failed to satisfy the 200 or so Americans who'd come with a sudden desire to be with their people. It's different for visiting tourists, but the Americans who actually live here go to great lengths to avoid one another. Now we wanted to hang out and share our emptiness, but it wasn't on the program.
仪式在电视上直播，所以虽然是美国教会，但布道是用法语进行的，牧师、拉比和穆斯林神职人员发表了简短演讲。一切都很得体，但未能满足那 200 多名怀着想要和同胞在一起的迫切愿望而来的美国人。对于来访的游客来说，情况不同，但真正住在这里的美国人却极力避免见面。现在我们想聚在一起分享我们的空虚，但这并不在日程表上。
The service ended, and just as the last politician filed out of the room, a man on the balcony started singing "God Bless America." It's a song I always associated with homeroom and high school sporting events, but under the circumstances, and on foreign soil, the lyrics became significant. The man started singing, and little by little, the rest of us joined in. The couples with bilingual children, the college students, the nannies, and across the aisle, soprano Jessye Norman, who placed her hand over her heart and sang as if she were just a normal shattered woman, rather than an opera star.
仪式结束时，就在最后一位政客走出房间时，阳台上的一名男子开始唱“上帝保佑美国”。这是一首我总是与班会和高中体育赛事联系在一起的歌，但在这种情况下，在异国他乡，歌词变得意义重大。那名男子开始唱，慢慢地，我们其余的人也加入了进来。带着双语孩子的夫妇、大学生、保姆，以及走道对面，女高音杰西·诺曼，她把手放在胸口，唱得就像一个普通的破碎的女人，而不是歌剧明星。
The thing about "God Bless America" is that after a certain point, nobody seems to know the words. "Stand beside her and guide her" is almost always followed by a prolonged mumbling that lasts until we reach the mountains and prairies. Then there's that strange bit about the oceans white with foam, which is odd in that it's not in any way a national phenomenon. Lots of countries have foam. They just don't talk about it.
关于“上帝保佑美国”，问题在于到了一定程度，似乎没人知道歌词。在“站在她身旁引导她”之后，几乎总是跟着一阵长时间的咕哝，直到我们到达“群山和草原”。然后还有那段关于“泡沫洁白的海洋”的奇怪部分，这很奇怪，因为它在任何意义上都不是一种全国性的现象。很多国家都有泡沫。他们只是不谈论它。
What killed me-- what killed us all-- was the very end. "My home sweet home." Because regardless of what we tell ourselves, Paris is not our home. It's just a place where we have our apartments and furniture. If it were our home, we'd have wanted to stay put, rather than catch the next flight back to New York or Kansas or wherever our family sat helpless in front of their televisions.
让我难以接受的是——让我们所有人难以接受的是——最后那部分。“我的甜蜜家园”。因为无论我们如何告诉自己，巴黎不是我们的家。它只是一个我们放公寓和家具的地方。如果是我们的家，我们会想留下来，而不是搭乘下一班航班飞回纽约或堪萨斯州，或者我们的家人在电视前无助地坐着的地方。
I worry here that in mentioning this moment, I only served to destroy it. To package what had felt genuine and pure. The days pass and I can no longer separate what I'm feeling from what I'm watching people feel on TV. Am I supposed to cry now? Am I supposed to feel proud, to feel pity? Everyone I talk to says the same thing. Tell us what to do and we'll do it.
我担心在这里提到这个时刻，我只是摧毁了它。把原本真诚和纯粹的东西包装了起来。日子一天天过去，我无法再把我的感受与我从电视上看到人们感受到的东西区分开来。我现在该哭吗？我该感到自豪、感到同情吗？我和每个人交谈，他们都说同样的话。告诉我们该做什么，我们就去做。
I'm told that in the United States, these loose feelings are being corralled towards retribution. But the French news is different. It doesn't point you one way or another. Rather, it just fills you up. I'm not seeing Bin Laden on an FBI wanted poster. I'm seeing him smiling amongst this comrades. And for the first few moments, I'm always mistaking him for Cat Stevens.
我被告知，在美国，这些松散的情绪正被引向报复。但法国新闻不同。它不会把你引向一个方向或另一个方向。相反，它只是让你满载。我没在联邦调查局的通缉令上看到本·拉登。我看到他在同伙中微笑。最初的几秒钟，我总是把他误认成猫·史蒂文斯。
The BBC has offered exhaustive coverage, but in the absence of breaking news, they, too have brought out their teddy bears. I heard that the survivors will need counseling. I heard that the rescue workers will need counseling. And then I heard that even the people who reportedly watched it on TV should consider talking to a professional. Now I'm hearing that our politicians need counseling. Although they're constantly surrounded by other people, the experts said, presidents can often feel terribly alone. It would be a lot easier if the terrorists sought counseling, but it's not going to happen.
英国广播公司提供了详尽的报道，但在没有突发新闻的情况下，他们也拿出了泰迪熊。我听说幸存者需要咨询。我听说救援人员需要咨询。然后我听说即使是那些在电视上观看报道的人也应该考虑找专业人士谈谈。现在我听说我们的政客需要咨询。专家们说，尽管总统经常被其他人包围，但他们往往会感到非常孤独。如果恐怖分子寻求咨询会容易得多，但这不会发生。
I don't understand how any of this offers the slightest bit of hope or comfort. But like everything else, I store it up.
我不明白这一切怎么能提供哪怕一丝希望或安慰。但像其他一切一样，我把它记在心里。
David Sedaris is the author of Me Talk Pretty One Day and other books.
大卫·塞达里斯是《我谈得漂亮的一天》及其他书籍的作者。
Act Five. USA, Me-SA.
第五幕。美国，我-国。
There's so many flags waved right now. But the trouble with the flag is that when it's waved, it can be waved for any of a number of different reasons. In the first day or two after the attack on the World Trade Center and the Pentagon, it seemed to me that the American flags all were being waved as a kind of act of mourning. It felt like, OK, we're all in this together.
现在挥舞着太多的旗帜。但旗帜的问题在于，当它被挥舞时，可能是为了许多不同原因中的任何一个。在世贸中心和五角大楼遭袭后的头一两天，在我看来，所有美国旗帜的挥舞都是一种哀悼。感觉像是，好了，我们都在一起。
And then in the days followed, as the president and other figures started to say that there's going to be a war, but without actually laying out any particular plans or details for what that war would be-- waving a flag started to feel like, it started to be like you were giving a red, white, and blue blank check to them to do whatever they wanted. I think, like a lot of people, speaking for myself, anyway, I wanted to hear a plan first before I cheered it on. It made me uneasy, all the flags, because of that.
接着随后的几天，当总统和其他人物开始说将会有一场战争，但实际上没有列出任何关于那场战争的计划或细节时——挥舞旗帜开始感觉像是，开始像是你给他们签了一张红、白、蓝三色的空白支票，让他们为所欲为。我想，就像许多人一样，至少就我个人而言，在欢呼之前，我想先听到一个计划。所有这些旗帜让我感到不安，因为这个原因。
I think there's a deeply American ideal of, you know, all of us banding together and doing what has to be done. And then there's an ideal which is exactly the opposite and just as deep as a tradition, which is to be completely skeptical of government and its intentions at all time. And like a lot of other patriotic people, I think I felt torn between the two.
我认为有一种深刻的美国理想，你知道，我们所有人都团结起来做必须做的事。然后还有一种理想恰恰相反，且作为一种传统同样深刻，那就是始终对政府及其意图保持彻底的怀疑。像许多其他爱国者一样，我觉得自己在两者之间被撕裂了。
Now, of course, the president has declared his intentions in his speech before Congress. But the flag still means different things to different people. A case in point. Here on Chicago's Southwest Side, every night during the week after the terrorist attacks, hundreds of cars jammed one particular neighborhood, honking and waving flags. Shirley Jahad went down there as part of the news team for WBEZ, The Public Radio station where we do our radio show from.
当然，现在总统已经在国会演讲中宣布了他的意图。但旗帜对不同的人仍然意味着不同的东西。举个例子。这里在芝加哥西南区，在恐怖袭击后的那一周里，每天晚上成百上千辆汽车挤在一个特定的社区，按喇叭挥舞旗帜。雪莉·贾哈德作为 WBEZ（我们电台节目所在的公共电台）新闻团队的一部分去了那里。
The location where they are right here is right in the midst of one of the biggest Arab-American communities in the region, and it's a block or so away from one of the bigger mosques in the region. The Bridgeview Mosque, yeah. So it takes on a whole different edge, the shouting of "USA, USA," by virtue of where they are and who they're surrounded by.
他们所在的这个地方就在该地区最大的阿拉伯裔美国人社区之一中间，距离该地区最大的清真寺之一仅一个街区左右。就是桥景清真寺。所以，凭借他们所在的位置以及他们周围的人，呼喊“美国，美国”带有了完全不同的边缘感。
Are there flags?
有旗帜吗？
Flags are everywhere. They're waving their flags out the window, they're draped over the back of the cars. There's people standing in the streets with these huge flags. Mostly all these people are youths. You know, young men. And so the groups of Arab-Americans are chanting back, "USA, USA. Yeah! USA USA."
到处都是旗帜。他们挥舞着旗帜伸出窗外，旗帜披在车后。街上站着挥舞巨幅旗帜的人。这些大多是年轻人。你知道，年轻男子。所以阿拉伯裔美国人的群体也在回喊，“美国，美国。耶！美国，美国。”
So each side is chanting USA?
所以双方都在喊美国？
So at some point, it was as if it were the Sharks and the Jets or something. I mean, each side on one side of the street, the Arab-Americans on one side of the street, the Anglo-Americans on the other side, all waving flags and all screaming at the top of their lungs "USA! USA! USA!" Some people are sort of spitting it, and some people are, you know? And then there's people driving by in the middle of the street with the flags and the horns.
在某种程度上，这就像是“鲨鱼”和“喷气机”之类的对抗。我的意思是，在街道的一侧，阿拉伯裔美国人，另一侧是盎格鲁-美国人，都在挥舞旗帜，都在扯着嗓子大喊“美国！美国！美国！”有些人带着唾沫横飞，有些人是，你知道的？然后街道中间还有挥着旗帜、鸣着喇叭开车经过的人。
And they're all chanting the same thing.
他们都在喊一样的话。
And they're all shouting the same thing.
But they mean something completely different when each of them shouts USA, USA, more or less.
但当他们各自呼喊“美国，美国”时，意思完全不同，多多少少是这样。
They mean completely different things. The white guys, when they're shouting USA, USA, they're basically saying, this is my country, and we want you out of here. You get out.
意思完全不同。那些白人小伙子，当他们喊“美国，美国”时，基本上是在说，这是我的国家，我们要你们滚出去。你们滚吧。
We're sick of the Arabians being here and we want them out of our country. Simply put they're screwing everything up, and they're taking all our money. And I think you can see the degradation in the neighborhoods that were once flourishing.
我们受够了阿拉伯人在这里，我们要他们滚出我们的国家。简单来说，他们把一切都搞砸了，他们拿走了我们所有的钱。而且我认为你可以看到那些曾经繁荣的社区在退化。
So basically this is a message for all the Arabs out there. You can just pack up and get your damn towels on the damn plane, right now.
所以基本上这是发给所有阿拉伯人的信息。你们可以滚蛋，带着你们该死的毛巾立刻滚上那架该死的飞机。
This was my land before it was theirs. I'm not going nowhere.
这片土地在他们之前就是我的。我哪儿也不去。
What if they were born here?
如果他们出生在这里呢？
Well, I don't give a [BLEEP] whether they were born here or not. Their ancestors weren't born there.
好吧，我不在乎他们是否出生在这里。他们的祖先没出生在那儿。
And so that means what?
那意味着什么？
So that means they came here. America let them in. And they [BLEEP] bombed the World Trade Center.
这意味着他们来到这里。美国让他们进来了。然后他们该死的炸了世贸中心。
Did you know my father served in the Korean War and I'm a Palestinian?
你知道我父亲参加过朝鲜战争，而且我是巴勒斯坦人吗？
Now Shirley, who is this guy?
现在雪莉，这人是谁？
This is an Arab-American guy, a Palestinian guy, who was leaving the mosque and he drove upon the scene.
这是一个阿拉伯裔美国人，一个巴勒斯坦人，他正离开清真寺，开车经过现场。
My grandfather served in World War II. Can you believe that? We're in 2001. This should not be happening.
我祖父参加过二战。你能相信吗？现在是 2001 年。这不应该发生。
You know, what was really interesting was the young man who said, you know, this is our country and we want them out of here, moments after he says this to me, he starts-- he continues shouting "USA, USA," and he's waving a flag. And then someone hands them a really, really big flag. It's a flag it takes two people to hold. So he's holding one end, and another white guy is holding the other end.
你知道，真正有趣的是那个说“这是我们的国家，我们要你们滚出这里”的年轻人，在我听到他这么说之后没多久，他开始——他继续呼喊“美国，美国”，挥舞着一面旗帜。然后有人递给他们一面非常、非常大的旗帜。那是一面需要两个人才能拿住的旗帜。所以他拿着一端，另一个白人拿着另一端。
But in the crush of the crowd, somehow the other end of the flag gets transferred to another young man, and the other person is an Arab-American. Now here's the white guy and the Arab-American and they're both holding the same American flag. And--
但在人群的拥挤中，不知怎么地，旗帜的另一端转到了另一个年轻人手中，而那个人是阿拉伯裔美国人。现在是白人和阿拉伯裔美国人，他们都在拿着同一面美国国旗。而且——
And is there a moment where they look up and each realize, where the white guy looks up and sees, oh?
他们有没有抬头意识到，白人抬头看到，噢？
Definitely. And the white guy is completely at a loss as to what to do, because he's put in this perplexing situation. He's holding Old Glory, and he can't let go, but he's holding it with an Arab-American. So he starts, like, holding it as if he's holding it with tweezers, like with just two fingers, and now he's trying to pass it off to somebody else. He can't drop it. He can't let go of it. Because it's the flag. So he's got to hold it.  So he holds it, and after a while, they walked together.
绝对有。那个白人完全不知道该怎么办，因为他陷入了一个令人困惑的境地。他拿着“老荣耀”，他不能放手，但他正和一个阿拉伯裔美国人拿着它。于是他开始，好像用镊子拿着它，只用两根手指，现在他试图把它转交给别人。他不能扔掉它。他不能松手。因为那是国旗。所以他必须拿着。所以他拿着它，过了一会儿，他们一起走了一段。
Down the street?
顺着街道？
Not for long. But they did walk together, and they actually started a conversation.
没走多远。但他们确实一起走了，而且他们真的开始了一段对话。
That conversation being, let go of the flag?
那段对话是，放开那面旗帜？
So I don't know how far they got.
所以我不知道他们走了多远。
WBEZ's Shirley Jahad.
WBEZ 的雪莉·贾哈德。
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Contributing editors Susan Burton, Rebecca Carroll, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Alix Spiegel, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Nancy Updike and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Diane Cook. Musical help for Mr. John Connors and Mr. Steve Cushing. Hi, Steve.
我们的节目今天由高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩。特约编辑苏珊·伯顿、丽贝卡·卡罗尔、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，[不可辨认] 宁西·厄普代克和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和黛安·库克提供制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯先生和史蒂夫·库欣先生提供音乐帮助。嗨，史蒂夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who this week is mute. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ 管理监督由托雷·马拉蒂亚负责，他这周失声了。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。